هذا الجسر يفصل بين الدولتين اوكرانيا و
بلاروسيا دمرته لقوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه
في الرابع والعشرين من فبراير مع بدايه
اجتياح الكامل للاراضي الاوكرانيه والذي
لم يكن ليكون بتلك الفعاليه والقدره على
الوصول وحصار العاصمه كيف لو لم تفتح دوله
فيلاروسيا حدودها امام جيش الاتحاد الروسي
لزحف نحو كيه التي تبعد من هذه النقطه
وانا اقف تماما على الحدود حوالي ثلاثه
ساعات في هذا الاتجاه شاص نظم النساء همم
اردني في هذا الجسر دمر في الرابع
والعشرين من فبراير العامه الماضي خلال
اجتياح الكامل للاراضي الاوكرانيه جنود
القوات المسلحه رصد تحرك المعدات العسكريه
القتاليه وكذلك المروحيات التي عبرت
الحدود والايقافهم عن الزحف نحو وعاصمتنا
كيف تم اتخاذ القرار من قبل حرس الحدود
بتفجير الجسر في الوقت الحالي ليس لديه
فرصه لتكرار ذلك
الاوكرانيون تعلموا الدرس فبعد ان
استطاعوا دفعوا لقوات الروسيه على
الانسحاب من حدودهم الشماليه عملوا على
تحصينها والدفعه بحرس الحدود ومشاهده
القوات المسلحه والمدفعيه الى الحدود
وقاموا ببناء تحصينات ابتداءا منكير وحتى
هنا اخر نقطه للمراقبه مع الحدودي
البيروسيه
الحدود
والقوات المسلحه وتجري عمليات مراقبه على
مدار الساعه على الجانب البلاستي كذلك
نعمل على مراقبه الاجواء ومراقبه نهر
بدوريات في الوقت الحالي لا توجد اي خلق
في الحدود ونحن نضع بعين الاعتبار كافه
السيناريوهات وجاهزون لاي ظرف الا ان ذلك
لم يكن كافيا خاصه وان الاستخبارات
العسكريه الاوكرانيه تتوقعه هجوما وزحفا
بريا جديدا من اراضي فيلاروسيا بعد ان
دفعوا الروسوا بنحو 20,000 جندي عدا من
كانوا متواجدين منذ بدايه الحربيه في
بيلاروسيا حيث قامت كيف ببناء جدار فاصل
بين البلدين على حدود الشماليه وعززته
بخنادقه وزرعه الالغامه على الشريط
الحدودي
الاجراءات التي قمنا بها في البدايه كانت
تدمير الجسور الرابطه بيننا سواء كانت
جسور النقل للسيارات او سكه الحديديه كما
قمنا بانشاء الدفاعات الهندسيه كالجدار
وموانع الدبابات وزرعنا الالغام على كامل
الحدود وحتى الطرق قمنا بتدميرها وكذلك
قطعنا الاشجار في الغابات
الخاصه والقوات المسلحه والقوات الدفاع
الاقليميه وغيرها من القوات المنضويه تحت
القوات المسلحه اوكرانيا
يضعون عده سيناريوهات قد يتبعها الجيش
الروسي ابرزها الزحف مجددا من اراضي
بيلاروسيا نحو كيه وهذه الحدود هي الاقرب
اليها او محاوله الزحف للسيطره على
الولايات الغربيه مما يسمح بقطع طريق
الامدادات العسكريه من الغرب ما يجعلها
حدودا ذات اهميه استراتيجيه كبيره في هذه
الحرب الى ان القياده الاوكرانيه تقول
انها واعيه للمخطط الروسي ومستعده
لمواجهته لدي فعادل لقناتي العربيه والحدث
من الحدود الاوكرانيه البلا الروسيه